In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinha Xarion from May 12th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Yermanos of Constantinople.
Our Holy Father Yermanos was the son of a famous and powerful patrician named Justinian,
whom the emperor Constantine IV, through jealousy, had executed.
He then made the young Yermanos a eunuch so that he would be unable to take up a post in
the Senate and had him placed among the clergy of the great church.
Making necessity an occasion of glory, blessed Yermanos led a life like that of the angels,
rejecting all worldly vanity and consecrating himself day and night to meditation on the
scriptures and the praise of God.
In this he gained a profound theological knowledge by which he was able to defend the true faith.
The fathers of the Second Council of Nysia praised him in the following terms.
Consecrated to God from his youth like the Prophet Samuel and an emulator of the Holy
Fathers, his writings spread throughout the world.
He had the praise of God on his lips and in his words as a two-edged sword in his hand,
against all the adversaries of the ecclesiastical traditions.
Consecrated metropolitan of Sizekas, he battled first against the remnants of the monothelyte
heresy which brought about his exile by Emperor Philippicus, who tried to revive this heresy.
From the tyrant's death Yermanos was re-established in his sea and elected patriarch of Constantinople
in 715 to the great joy of all the Orthodox people.
He adorned the patriarchal throne with his virtues and his gift of prophecy.
On the day of the baptism of Emperor Leo III's son Constantine, St. Germano's prophesied
that the latter would become a formidable enemy of the church, and he predicted to Anastasius,
one of his priests, that he would usurp his throne and become one of the promoters of heresy.
At the beginning of Leo III's reign, Constantinople was besieged by a vast Arab army and it was only
through the protection of the mother of God and the urgent prayers of the people led by St. Germano's
that the city escaped from danger in 718.
After reigning for about twelve years, the emperor began to reveal his impious intentions
and to speak against the veneration of the holy images, announcing that he was going to remove
them from public worship in the year 726.
The holy patriarch then confronted the emperor, reproaching him for his interference in the affairs
of the church and his transgression of venerable traditions that had been instituted in apostolic
times.
And the word of God became incarnate, becoming a human being in our likeness, he assumed our
nature in order to renew in us the image of God which had been tarnished by sin.
Therefore to attack the veneration of the holy icons was to invalidate the whole mystery
of the incarnation.
The saint declared himself ready to die for the image of the Lord and entreated the sovereign
to cease troubling the church by such designs.
Finding no arguments against his words Leo in a fit of rage struck the saint and threw
him out.
He summoned the master of the patriarchal school who confirmed the ancient traditional nature
of the veneration of images, furious and beside himself the emperor sent his troops to the
school.
They burned thousands of volumes, thousands of volumes of its library and threw them into
the sea.
After the incident of the icon of the bronze door the emperor summoned the saint and on
the 17th of January in the year 730 brought him by force before a great assembly of senators
and high dignitaries in order to make him accept his decree ordering the general destruction
of the holy icons in the whole of the empire.
Yet Manus, however, addressed them with a brilliant defense of the true faith and concluded by
saying,
If I am a second Jonah, throw me into the sea.
Yet no, O emperor, that without an ecumenical counsel, I am not able to make innovations
in matters of faith.
Then going to Saint Sophia's he took off his homophorium, placed it on the holy table and
left for Platonion, a family property where he ended his days in the year 730 or possibly
the year 742 in solitude and prayer, writing various treaties against heresy.
Five days after Saint Germano's resignation the emperor had his unprinciple disciple Anastasius
consecrated as patriarch, just as Saint Germano's had predicted.
Anastasius made himself the emperor's accomplice and encouraged the persecution of all the clergy,
monks and layfolk who continued to venerate the holy images.
It is said that after his abdication, Saint Germano's taking the icon of the mother of
God in his arms, threw it into the sea in the Amantios district, imploring Christ to guide
it to Rome so that his brother in the Episcopate, the Pope of Rome, far from the intrigues of
the tyrant might be the guardian of the holy traditions.
At the end of the iconoclast heresy in the year 843, the icon returned to Constantinople
by itself on the waves and was given to Empress Theodora who placed it in the church of the
Calcupritea through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy
on us and save us.